TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for The Developer Show.
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Actions on Google
has new features
that enable you to
be more creative
and to build new
types of actions
that help your users
get more things done.
These include support for
media playback, better content
carousels, and daily updates and
push notifications on phones.
Take a look at the post
linked in the description
below for all the details.
The first developer preview
of Android P is now available.
It's an early baseline
build for developers only.
That's you.
New features include
indoor positioning
with Wi-Fi RTT, improved
messaging notifications,
and a multi-camera API.
Take a look at the post for the
Getting Started instructions.
Android Things is
Google's platform
that enables Android
developers to create
Internet of Things devices.
The platform also supports
powerful applications
such as video and
audio processing
and onboard machine
learning with TensorFlow.
Developer Preview
7 is now available
with console enhancements,
device updates, and more.
Chrome 65 is out and it includes
the CSS Paint API, the Server
Timing API, and more.
Take a look at the post for
everything new for developers
in this release.
As the top ranked mobile
app crash reporter
for over three years
running, Crashlytics
helps you track, prioritize,
and fix stability issues
in real time.
We recently graduated Firebase
Crashlytics out of beta,
making it the default
crash reporter
for Firebase going forward.
This release includes
several major new features,
which are outlined in the post.
Now available in Public Alpha
is an interactive command line
interface to Google
Cloud Platform
that provides auto
prompts and inline
help for GCloud, GS Util, BQ,
and Cube Control commands.
This means no more
context switching
as you search for command names,
required flags, or argument
types in Help pages.
Screen shots and getting started
instructions are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Did I mention that
I have jet lag?
Whew.
OK, let's do this.